I'm on the 19th for one counter square
in London and that is a gorgeous sunset
and soon the Sun will dip below the
horizon and it will be Twilight sea
night doesn't technically start at least
under formal definitions until the Sun
is 18 degrees below the horizon and
until then there are three types of
Twilight first of all there is civil
twilight that's when the sky is still
fairly light and you can walk about
without worrying vinick's trip over
something that's zero to six degrees
below the horizon next up is nautical
Twilight that's where you can just about
see the horizon against the sky if
you're navigating on a bunch that's six
to twelve degrees and finally there is
astronomical Twilight where it's still
just a little bit too light for the the
really faint objects like nebulae and
galaxies to come out in the sky that
twelve to eighteen degrees and then
finally when the Sun dips under that
then it formally becomes night but the
thing is in mid summer when it's really
really bright when it's that Sun high in
the sky the United Kingdom is north
enough that it never becomes night that
from evening to morning we are
perpetually in Twilight until finally
autumn rolls around and we dip into
night
once again America doesn't quite get it
Vancouver in Canada just stretches into
that definition but the whole of the UK
and of course a lot of northern Europe
well we have entire seasons where we
never ever technically have night that
is Twilight that is a really gorgeous
sunset and that is something you might
not have known